MALE SPEAKER: Are you ready?
SHANEE: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Set?
SHANEE: Yep.
MALE SPEAKER: Go!
SHANEE: Hi, everyone.
I'm a programmer.
How many of you guys
are programmers?
Hands, come on, hands!
Hm-- that's a good ratio.
So my presentation
is a bit technical.
But they feel it's
quite important.
It's about things which
we do in our game code
and pretty much [INAUDIBLE]
since we can optimize and do
better to improve it.
So I have seven points, "The
Seven Sins of Android Game
Developers," and
let's get into them.
So number one, Android
mobile internal
is pretty much just
like PC and console.
So many lessons we have
learned, and they still apply.
So there is a lot of
common knowledge out there,
and we should use
it more in our game.
A lot of what's
coming are examples.
So let's take this
code, for example.
We have two methods.
They're pretty much the
same, iterating an array.
But by one time, we
are incrementing by 1,
and the other time, we
are incrementing by 16.
So it's pretty much the same.
No tricks, right?
So what happens?
You'd expect for performance
it would be exactly the same.
So I've put it into a benchmark.
And the results are
quite astonishing.
When you look into
the graph, you
see that it's just
about five times
slower when you increment the
data by 16 bytes at the time.
What's going on here?
So beyond the software,
we also have our hardware.
We have our CPU and the cache.
And when you want to send data
to be transformed in the cache,
it needs to be laid out in
a way so it can read it.
If the cache doesn't have the
data, that you get the cache
miss, and it needs
to be copied into it.
So that can literally double
or times 5 your performance.
And then the end
lesson is that's when
you're making your
code, you really
need to think about your data.
So make design for
the many, not the one.
Always have a lot of physics
objects, not just one.
Number three, thou shalt
not abuse thy draw calls.
We want to make a huge army,
a crowd, a forest, or just
a nice field of grass maybe.
And for doing that, we
have a lot of draw calls.
But when we do it, we need
to send a command to the GPU.
So we need to sync with
another [INAUDIBLE].
We need hardware.
We communicate with the drivers,
and always through CPU cycles.
And then we do it again,
and again, and again.
And we're not really
doing any good work.
To fix that, there's a technique
called geometry instancing.
This is available
from OpenGL ES 3.0.
So we have our meta
data on one platform
and the per-instance
data on another.
That's the big world view
projection and the color.
And we draw a lot objects at
once with just one draw call.
Next, do not
decompress on the CPU.
We have PNG, and we
have JPG, and WebP,
and we really want to use
them to lower our upsize.
But then we need
to decompress them
before we can copy
them to the GPU.
So not only the decompression
doesn't help us,
because it's for size
again, we are also
wasting time on loading.
On the other hand, how I
accelerate the textures
like ASTC or DXT can
just be copied as is.
All you need to do is
create a header and copy it.
So not only do you
gain time on loading,
because you don't
need to decompress
them, you're also
gaining your size again.
Your antimemory is smaller.
And sometimes, it's even
smaller than PNG can do.
It's [INAUDIBLE], but
it's relatively good.
Number five, do not
totally redundancy.
You'll have your shader
and you have your uniforms.
And you need to do a
glGetUniformLocation
my uniform name.
And this is relatively slow.
And if you're doing
it on charcoal and not
on [INAUDIBLE], go to
your code now and fix it.
Put it on [INAUDIBLE].
But what if we
didn't need to do it?
What if we could always
know where our uniforms are?
So with OpenGL ES 3.1, we
can change the top shader
to the bottom one.
We always know
where everything is.
This is deterministic.
Number six, do not dismiss
cool new technology.
With Android Extension
Pack, we have
compute shaders and
[? distillation. ?]
We can use them for
amazing levels of detail
or putting in our physics into
GPU for a higher performance.
I have a video from ARM here.
This is showing
a 3D ASTC texture
all in the GPU with
compute shaders
doing the particle physics.
This is all under
GPU, nothing else.
And you can expand it and use
it for procedurally generated
geometry like
terrain and foxholes.
How amazing is that?
Number seven, do not
disrespect thy hardware.
Android is quite a new platform.
But if we look at the
performance for the past four
years only, we can see the
performance is more than
doubling every year.
And the chart is going
to up and faster.
That's all.
[APPLAUSE]